um tell me like man how do you go about
business ventures because I feel like
you're one of the more like
entrepreneurials just minded artists
we've had in the last 15 years I think
back to like yums and obviously you've
had shoes and you've you've had so many
things that we can point our finger to
and be like man soldier boy just you're
a hustler bro for real now for sure man
like that's how I've been since day one
like I always trying to get some money
man you know when it come to businesses
I just do stuff that I'm interested in
you know what I'm saying like video game
console clothing fashion
you know the blind I got the soldier
blunts with signature shout out to
Signature my man Tiara you got Soldier
Bloods yes Soldier blunt raps you know
I'm saying black cherry flavor you know
I'm saying signature smoke brand my boy
T.I he put that together you know I'm
saying shot big shout out to him
um I just I just I gotta get a bag kill
we gotta Get This Money Man by any means
necessary around me so
you know but we're just doing we're
doing what we like though you feel me I
rock with the fashion Soulja Boy apparel
I we've spent all this money on Gucci we
spent all this money on Louis Vuitton
why we can't come out with our own
clothing line people support you feeling
I mean you had a very big clothing line
that's a fact and that's and that's what
it's all about I mean yeah I'm just
running rampant for a couple of years
yeah and it's like you like man I got I
got dreams too I got a vision too you
feel what I'm saying I'll be looking at
Gucci I'm looking at Louis how big it is
so I'm trying to be on that level you
feel me uh what have because I've last
time you were here we talked about the
video game console and I know you've had
some you know a couple of complications
with rolling it out but I but you have
been pretty transparent with your fans
on what's going on you know with with
the video game console what is going on
with the video game console we just did
a deal with Walmart man shout out to
Walmart we in all Walmarts you know
saying y'all go walmart.com go order
today so I was a boy game trdr pocket
um we just added artificial intelligence
into AI you know what I'm saying so high
on the iPhone you can talk to Siri video
game console you could talk to it and
talk back to you you know what I'm
saying we'll talk back in your voice we
got that too you didn't because that
would be crazy so you know but um it was
a hard process you know but we here now
you feel me and I want to thank Walmart
for being the first big you know store
to support me you know what I'm saying
and we got we about to go into like uh
four more stores in the next couple
months that's big man I'll be on lookout
for that so it's like people buy the
console it comes pre-loaded you can get
whatever you want on their games Spotify
Apple music you know I'm saying it's a
whole whole platform me whatever you
want to get yeah y'all go get that album
season album off the console you could
listen to it on the soldier what's the
name of the video game Soulja Boy game
soldier boy you can see you're fully
vertical at this point you know what I'm
saying yeah
how do you think artificial intelligence
uh is gonna change the rap game because
you know you I'm sure you've seen a lot
of these crazy uh
likes fake songs from artists yeah I
mean I just feel like you know I don't
know we gotta we got it's still new so
we gotta wait and see like I want
somebody to take someone random like
Adele and make an AI version of Adele
doing crank that that's hard
let's do it someone's gonna do that out
there because they're gonna see this
yeah somebody's gonna like it's possibly
the possibilities is endless man you can
do so much stuff but it's at the end of
the day it could be a good thing it
could be a bad thing you just gotta wait
and see how do you think it could be bad
you know people use it in the wrong way
you know what I'm saying or you know do
you have a are you like pretty hip to
the uh like you know just the AI [__] in
general you have you have you [__]
around on chat gbt yet yeah I I I've
been I've been you know on through all
the AIS you dig what I'm saying chat GPT
and all that you know what did you what
did you converse with chat gbt about
because I actually know artists who have
asked
chat GPT what they should do for their
album rollout yeah and like it'll write
like a 10 paragraph like album roll out
now I know no it's funny like
the [__] that I I typed in a couple
things but the [__] that I typed in it
was like oh I can't help you with that
all right sir that's right timing in
some others I was trying to figure out
how to hit okay okay where's the G-spot
just know that they have no answer for
me they said I can't help you with this
sir I said then I'll close the app out
they said this is this this is you know
we can't we can't help you with this